Speaker 1: I know when I tell you the following
headline, many of you will say, Is this a rerun,
David? Is this a 2020 episode or a 2021 episode?
No, it is almost October of 2022. And 61% of
Republicans still think that Donald Trump actually
won the 2020 presidential election. It is almost
October of 2022. Monmouth poll shows, according
to NBC News, that nearly a third of all Americans,
including six in ten Republicans, continue to hold
the debunked belief that President Joe Biden did
not win the 2020 election legitimately. This is
a new Monmouth University poll released the day
before the January six committee was going to
hold a hearing because of the hurricane. The
January six committee has canceled today's hearing
just as an FBI. 29% of all respondents, as well as
61% of Republicans say that Joe Biden won due to
voter fraud due to voter fraud. Can you imagine?
These numbers have been relatively consistent over
time. If you look at the chart, you see that late
in 2020 and throughout most of 2021, about 32%
of all Americans believed Biden won due to voter
fraud. That is down just slightly in 2022 to 29%.
These are incredible numbers that the world sees
and says, what the hell is going on in the United
States? And they are right to ask that question.
You really. How do you share a country
and how do you run a government
split with individuals who believe the system
only works when they win? That's fundamentally
what this is. You know, many of you wrote to
me after my interview yesterday with Republican
candidate Alison Hayden. The interview was
a complete mess. Complete and total mess.
She's running against Eric Swalwell in California,
our friend Eric Swalwell, who, by the way,
I obviously support Swalwell over Alison Hayden
in that race. In case I didn't make it completely
clear during the interview and people wrote to me
and said, you know, David, an interesting question
to ask folks like this. People like Alison Hayden
who say, no, no, no, no, you can't trust the
election results. Would they be flipping out the
way they've been flipping out about voter fraud
and election integrity since November of 2020?
Would they be doing the same thing if the results
had shown Trump had won? Because they claim that
their concern is not about who won. That their
concern is about the process as I lose my earpiece
here due to excitement. They say the concern is
about the process and the handling of the ballots
and the integrity of how everything was handled.
Would they be behaving the same way if it had
been Donald Trump who had won under the exact
same circumstances? And of course, we all know
the answer, and that gets us down to this very
again. I know we use this. It's like five
times a show. We get to this point. This is
extraordinarily authoritarian. The system can
be trusted when I've won and when I've lost. It
is a systemic problem that we need to fix. Now
there is probably some imagine a Venn diagram,
the people who believe Trump won in 2020 and
the people who believe that Barack Obama was
not really born in the United States. My guess
is there's a pretty significant overlap between
those two groups, and it really shows the power
of endlessly repeating a lie to some degree, some
of that 61%. You and I know they don't literally
believe that Donald Trump won in November of 2020,
but it's a combination of other things. Some of
the 61% that are saying, I believe Trump won say
it because it signals membership in a team. And
we've talked about this before. You have to show
that you're part of the team and you show that by
saying Donald Trump actually is the winner of the
2020 election. Others have a cognitive dissonance
where they simply can't admit even to themselves
they were bamboozled by a very mediocre charlatan.
That's what happened. And the way that they avoid
admitting that to themselves is by saying, Oh,
the guy actually won. The guy I supported actually
is the winner. And so there's a lot of group
psychology at play. There's a lot of magical
thinking. There's a lot of non thinking at play.
But it's all extremely demoralizing when we say,
Hey, you know, we should at least be able to agree
on some basis of fact here. And unfortunately,
we can't do that. 61% of Republicans don't
believe Joe Biden won the 2020 election